My tumor markers continue to go up by oncologist isn't real concerned yet about the tumor markers, but is concerned about the tumor coming to the surface. The tumor seems to be getting more painful around the tumor.
I also have an additional lymph node that is popping up in the neck. He wants to raise my eyebrows to 100 milligrams.
If I'm okay with this, also, he said that he is budding that letters all is not killing the cancer like it used to, but rather will be a full of a stront, which is a different drug.
So I do agree that sometimes you have to switch up drug. So I would be, you know, I think that you have to refer to him about that. I think that would be if I was in your situation, I would probably do that.
When I increase the eyebrows to 100 possibly the tumor marker is continuing to rise by concerned with that is our is is the cancer decreasing. Now he thinks well, that could be because the cancer is dying.
That's because you went back on the eyebrows and that could be very well true. Remember, that's why a lot of oncologists don't want to run to markers if you're on a chemotherapy because your tumor markers can actually go up to begin with.
And that could get scary, but he's still making which I like to see this he's making a more clinical judgment, not just completely based on one test.
I do not want to go on the shot if I don't have to because of the horrible hot flashes. Now you better remember the horrible hot flashes are actually an indication that it's working.
So we've talked about this multiple times these zoom calls.
How do I get rid of the hot flashes that have under estrogen.
Reducing drug, well, the idea is that if you're out of estrogen, reducing drug and it's working, you're going to have hot flashes and if you take something like soy.
Uh, flavonoids, like, jeniston, you can help reduce the hot flashes, but you're, you're, you're, it's conflicting because you are actually adding estrogen, your whole idea is you're trying to get rid of estrogen.
So you're, why do the drug in the first place then. So, um, that's why I disagree with this thing about Ralph losses because you can take a person with that's going through menopause and put them on a.
So a estrogen, maybe of a, uh, jeniston and it will actually reduce their symptoms because it's estrogen like.
And it acts as estrogen, well, it will also act as estrogen to the beta receptor of the estrogen beta receptor and cause issues with decreasing apoptosis.
Uh, what are your thoughts on this about upbeat eyebrows or about I'm all for it and see how everything is looking before changing everything at once. I'm all for that.
And if he thinks that you're not responding to the letters on going to this, I would, I would refer to that.